another thing that I feel makes you work
very enjoyable is that the reader
suffers because danger feels real and no
connector is safe and I think that
another offer that does this pretty well
too is george RR martin mean we know
each other personally so I told him once
he's doing a economical thing with the
shows he's kidding them with no reason
leading the killers must have arisen and
he said the reason is that the reader is
angry yes it makes me angry
I don't know although the The Witcher
has mythological references one of the
most interesting things and I'm sure
that people here who have read The
Witcher agree is that your characters
hardly behave like conventional myths
and I'm talking about vampires who
doctors blood mercenaries with honour
and really troubled sorcerers is that a
reaction I get against bad fantasy where
everybody is super powerful and boring
absolutely absolutely because as I told
you before I started my right I knew the
Canon of the science fiction and fantasy
quite well and I could decide Josh
what's good what's bad what's it just a
cliche and what's a guy could new and
refreshing invention it was when I
started writing I said yes I write the
wind on these arrows these mistakes I
will not commit because I know all the
traps on the way I know only so I just
can't make a little solemn just know
avoid all these just any mistakes and
yes
is it when you are meant to do if you
are not a just a boy who is writing
about killing orcs and then kill God and
then killing orcs and second is [ __ ]
somebody and then kill more or 45 years
old and start writing you are a little
bit better and as some you know a
supreme as the guy who is what I mean
when one talks about fantasy it's almost
mandatory to kind of bring up Tolkien
and I know it's an author that you
admired as a writer what do you think
that if what do you think it is that
makes this work so unique and so
imitated well he was the first oh
there's been many copies why do you
think that his still persist to be that
the person when he did of the first that
he was good so really even if do not
believe how many fantasy novels of
series I have read about a bunch of guys
going on the quest or the travel who
join me Johnny westerns and training
your Chinese or does that with job in
the West do drop a leak into the working
hundreds of novel about it but you know
good things have this in it maybe not
easy to imitate because you cannot
imitate the consumer you'll be always
worse than the goods but what the thing
I mean for me good fiction is that
you read it it makes it so obvious that
this is such a good at the end why
nobody had it before and it's always
been here but then when someone tries to
do it again it is before this in a way
no before before John rolling I read a
lot of novels about the school of
wizards and sorcery
she brought on all the world our aunt
Denise no wonder because I don't know if
you have read all the Harry Potter
novels I I did go to the tree just good
so keeping with dokyun his work drama
from Scandinavian myths and maybe
because fantasy at least in one area is
dominated by anglo-saxon authors we are
not so familiar with the Polish incited
mythology that you weave in a work and I
was wondering if there's a punishment
that you find particularly compelling
and you would like to tell us about too
just not only polish but if at the
salami for me it was just the same
because brothers Dean it was in lorries
and they said oh it is America in the
Six Nations connected to any kind of
Mythology
any kind of mechanism is not influencing
me to this extent that I consider in
people not the way
one of the things that I think when
someone tackles your sanga's is that
you're definitely a specialist in
fantasy but you also bring your your
background as an economist it feels like
in your books the laws of cause and
effect apply that magic has a price
King things go to war for money it's not
like you in bad fantasy but you know you
never feel the gravity of a situation or
you just think that things happen
randomly in yours things you know
economics and socio economics have a
have a deal
do you think this is part of your
training as an economist and you spend
in economics do you think this has an
influence in your work some wise guy
maybe an author of science fiction some
today fantasy is improbable none of is
impossible make Conrado
so of course dragons as we consider
Dwarfs magic sorcerers which are
impossible but fantasy makes the problem
and what is probable in also in fantasy
how can you how can you convince the
reader that what you write is not all
these stupid things about some
non-existent dragons or impossible
Dwarfs it is making it real so everybody
must have the way to sustain himself to
make a living
the banks must operate the currency must
be compared to the currency of the other
country so it's the value of something
and the six of course in my preparation
as an economist helped me a lot because
I know what is a currency how to deal
with something how to sell things and to
buy things and not absolutely easier for
me that for the Nets a science fiction
writer who has no such preparation look
at the words of Spanish La Fleur
it was a from if beginning was a doctor
with medicine and you can find something
several from medicine in his works but
you will never find in the word so
studies of like nothing with a comedy
he just avoided